hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
secure your next great discovery i am
jennifer woods of labruz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruth and brought to you
by eppendorf
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
paulina katzian
and kate miola from the eppendorf team
and
zade zarubayan who also goes by zee
director of e-lab next speaker
you may now begin your presentation
thank you so much jennifer so
hi everyone thank you again for being
here today
my name is my name is paulina and in
this webinar we're going to be talking
about the importance of your sample
and what a comprehensive sample
management solution looks like and how
it can actually benefit
you in your lab
let's just take a look at the agenda and
kind of what we're going to step through
so really first we want to talk about
you know your samples what types of
samples do you work with
in the lab um you know why are they so
valuable
so you know every day in and out of the
lab you're working with these samples
you're storing them you're processing
them
what samples are these and kind of you
know what makes them so important
then we really want to talk about sample
management
so we want to talk about you know what
types of issues
do you typically run into you know when
you don't have a sample management
system
in your lab and how can you actually
resolve them
and then last but not least we want to
talk about kind of the eppendorf
solution
so sample 360 which is going to be
really the end to end solution
for how to transform your sample
management
so let's talk about your samples in the
lab
so there are multiple types of samples
you typically work with
from dna rna to cells bacteria
and more so what types of samples are we
going to focus on today
we want to talk about the samples you
store in your negative 80
ult freezer your dna rna
antibodies tissues specimens etc so
anything that you would have for
long-term
storage in your freezer
so what makes your samples so valuable
you can spend a lot of time preparing
your samples
before storing such as bacterial strains
of interest
that are needed for further downstream
processes
so that's kind of already the initial
thing that makes them already so
valuable the next thing is the reagents
and consumables they could typically be
very costly
in the lab for prepping and for storing
your samples
reaction miniaturization is becoming
more prevalent
in genomics applications to scale down
reaction volumes in order to achieve
cost saving
additionally in many experiments
technical replicas replicates are needed
to address the reproducibility of the
assay or method
your data is dependent on your sample
security
if your samples cannot be clearly
identified at any point throughout your
research
then the data you generate will not be
reliable
since you would not know if you're using
the correct sample throughout your
workflow
then your results could not be trusted
and finally many of your samples stored
at negative adc
are the original and cannot be replaced
so that's kind of one of the biggest top
things is that in many labs
you know you might have an official
sample like your ffbe sample
or whatever it is that you're storing in
your negative 80 and they cannot be
replaced so
once you lose it or you can't correctly
identify it then
it is gone so in the end
your samples are basically priceless
so your samples are everything so by
improving how you manage them
you are not only ensuring their security
but also the reliability of your results
your next discovery could be key in
improving human health
sustaining and restoring our environment
protecting
endangered species or understanding the
diversity and significance
of microbes to just name a few
now let's look at how the mismanagement
of your samples could lead to
difficulties
that can inhibit you from moving forward
in your research
you care about your research and
validating your findings
which means your samples need to be a
priority as well
so let's see kind of what happens when
your samples are not a priority
this is the first example we're going to
go through
so accurate sample tracking is key in
most laboratories
for the ability to identify a sample
after collection
its location volume and steps it has
taken in a process
sample traceability can be lost due to
mismanagement of sample
which can lead to then wasted time
and effort preparing these samples in
the end
this can also result in delays
that mean that you could either have
lost your sample or
you know you basically cannot then meet
your project
deadlines so this is just showing the
path
of the mismanagement of your samples
when you don't put your samples
as priority so sample traceability is
super important because it's not just
about you know tracking your samples
but in the end if you lose your samples
and cannot properly track them they
could lead to larger project
delays
another example is the improper storage
of your samples
which could cause degradation making it
difficult
to complete experiments
so now you'll probably have to repeat
your experiments
if the sample can still be obtained
when you store your samples in the
freezer overnight to go home
or work on data analysis at your desk
others can access the freezer during
this time
someone else might leave the freezer
door open too long or move your sample
to a different location while looking
for theirs
your samples are very important and
should be managed
properly to ensure their safety and
again we go through that same path
of you know if your sample is degraded
again you have unreliable data
and you might need to repeat your
experiments if you even can
if you're able to kate will now go
further
into the types of issues you can run
into without
proper sample management
okay thanks paulina so
we've seen why your samples are so
valuable
and why you should make how you manage
them a priority
now let's take a look at some of the
challenges you face when managing your
samples
and if you're struggling with sample
management i'm sure some of these will
look very familiar to you
so first up we have sample
identification issues
so when was the last time you opened the
freezer and found a sample that was
labeled like this one on the left
can you read what that says if so your
eyes are definitely better than mine
even if you're the one who wrote it you
may not be able to remember what it says
months later which doesn't help much
when you're trying to find that one
specific
sample that is crucial to your research
writing on tubes can also wear off
during storage or
processing either with regular wear or
due to certain chemicals
samples can also be mislabeled with
incorrect identification
printed labels like the one on the right
are certainly an improvement over
handwritten labels
but these can also fall off during
storage or processing
and they still require you to read each
individual sample to find the one you
need
if the sample can't be identified it
also can't be traced
remember that as paulina said earlier
inability to identify your samples
correctly
may lead to unreliable data
then there's sample storage so many
people don't realize that
how you store your samples is just as
important as how you handle them
a disorganized freezer like this one not
only wastes your time as you search for
the right sample
but it also wastes valuable space in
your freezer
if you don't know what's in there how do
you know if you really need it
you may think that you're running out of
space when in fact 30
or even more of what you're storing in
your freezer might be completely
unnecessary
so wasting time looking for samples
could also lead to inaccurate data
how well besides not being able to find
the correct sample in this entire mess
here
the longer the freezer door remains open
the greater the temperature fluctuation
in the chamber
over time continuous temperature
fluctuations
from long door openings can lead to
degradation
and impact the integrity of your samples
potentially affecting your results
leaving the door open for too long or
using a freezer without proper
insulation
can also cause ice buildup as the warm
moist air from the outside environment
combines with the ultra low temperatures
inside the freezer
creating the dreaded frost everyone
knows about this one
this buildup is not only incredibly
annoying
but it can cause additional problems by
preventing a tight seal of the freezer
door
which as you might guess leads to
even more frost if you're sharing the
freezer in the lab with others you also
can't control who has access
nor can you monitor when and for how
long they are leaving the freezer door
open
there's also the unexpected human
element to consider
not only do you
excuse me not only can people keep the
door open too long
or fail to close the door properly
but i heard a story recently in which
the contents of the freezer were lost
because the freezer was accidentally
switched off by a maintenance worker
who happened to be working near the
freezer so
these things do happen a lab is a busy
place and
accidents like this can occur
another big issue with sample storage is
energy consumption
older ult freezers are inefficient and
can consume huge amounts of energy
affecting both your budget and the
planet
older model ults can actually use as
much energy in a day as an
entire household and the classic cooling
liquids they use
including chlorofluorocarbons and
hydrofluorocarbons
have been proven to be potent greenhouse
gases
so moving on what about documentation
you don't properly document the location
of your samples
or the data you have collected related
to the sample
details may be lost and your project
data can be inaccurate or incomplete
you can also be non-compliant with
regulations
all steps of your experimental methods
including sample data
need to be properly documented when that
data is scattered in different places
such as
multiple paper lab notebooks or excel
files
it's more difficult to track and more
easily compromised
and then finally we have sample
management
inefficiencies so how many times have
you had this
same thought if you've gone into the lab
on the weekend
just to check on your freezer then you
know what i'm talking about
when you leave the lab for the day or
for the weekend
you don't know what is happening while
you're away if something goes wrong
an alarm may sound but that doesn't help
anyone if there's no one there to hear
it and take corrective action
alarms alone don't ensure safety
additionally lab devices need regular
maintenance
but with so much activity going on in
the lab it's easy to forget to change
the filter
or to check the backup battery i will
tell you that a power outage is a
terrible time to find out that your
backup battery is not working
again these things do happen
so how do we solve these issues
well i'm happy to tell you that no
matter what the current state of your
sample management
there are steps you can take to get
yourself and your lab
back on track
for example switching to permanently
barcoded sample vials and tubes
ensures proper identification every time
these labels won't rub off or fall off
and they can easily be scanned
and uploaded into a data management
system that can securely store
all of your sample data in one
centralized location
you can also use this software to manage
your inventory
and visually locate your sample before
you ever open the sample door
the freezer door rather to make sure
your samples are protected
while they're being stored use a high
quality freezer that includes
heavy duty installation a robust
compressor
doors with advanced gaskets that prevent
frost buildup
and additional safety features like
electronic locks and unique user access
equip your freezer with a co2 or liquid
nitrogen backup system
to keep samples protected in case of
failure
to ensure energy efficiency and
sustainability
look for freezers that are energy star
rated act
certified and utilize natural
eco-friendly coolants
organize your freezer with racks and
storage boxes
these help maximize the available space
and keep samples easily accessible
use a digital platform that allows you
to remotely monitor your storage devices
when you are away from the lab
and to set regular maintenance reminders
remote monitoring
ensures that you're notified of alarms
immediately so that proper action can be
taken
to protect your samples you could even
take it a step further by digitizing
your lab with smart solutions
that enable connectivity throughout the
lab
remember proper sample management
leads to reliable data and confidence in
your results
which could lead to your next great
discovery
so let's put it all together if you're
asking yourself
what would comprehensive sample
management system look like in my lab
well i'm glad you asked let's have a
look now at sample 360.
solution for end to end ultra low
temperature sample management
the integrated family of products and
services provides a 360 degree view and
confidence at every step each element of
the solution
works seamlessly together to ensure that
your data is secure
and your results are reliable knowing
that your samples are protected
means more time for your research
sample epidural sample 360 includes
products to secure
store track and monitor your samples
use the entire family of products
together for a complete sample
management solution
or just use the individual components of
sample 360 as needed
to round out your current sample
management system
the sample 360 solution includes
barcoded storage files
ultra low temperature freezers software
for managing and tracking your sample
inventory
and a digital platform for lab
monitoring
paulina will now start to walk us
through
products that are part of the solution
molina awesome thank you kate
so the first part of this solution
um of a sample 360 solution as kate
mentioned is the bar-coded vials
so the eppendorf safe code system
ensures the security of your samples
these barcoded cryo storage vials
utilize a three-level coding
for reliable identification of your
samples throughout your workflow
so first a 2d data matrix with an ecc200
meaning that they could be damaged up to
30 percent
and still red a 1d classic barcode
and a readable numeric id
additional documentation is also
available
on the eppendorf website with
information for each file such as volume
lot number and certificates of quality
so all that information that you're
looking for could be
found on that eppendorf data port um
and all that information is going to be
in one place so you know that your
samples are secure
so safe code these barcoded vessels are
available
in multiple formats so they come from
0.5
to 4 mils and so they're basically able
to work with a wide variety of
applications so whether you're storing
things in point five or
four mills or whatever you need during
your processing um
they're available in many different
types of formats
additionally they come pre-capped and
pre-racked for easy handling
so you don't have to worry about
organizing them in a rack
additionally the twist lock bottom of
the tubes
also prevents the vials from rotating
within the rack
when being opened for easy and even
automated
capping and uncapping kate will now
talk about the storage of these samples
yeah thanks paulina okay so
let's keep going uh
a high quality freezer is a crucial
for ensuring the safety of your samples
with 21.1
26.1 cubic feet of storage space
the cryotube f-740hi features vacuum
insulation paneling
combined with polyurethane foam
insulation all around the freezer
including in the door to keep warm air
out and cold air in
flat flexible gaskets instead of the
typical accordion style gaskets
prevent ice buildup and are also easy to
clean
together they ensure short recovery
times after door opening
and long warm-up time in case of a power
failure
a locking switch plate prevents that
accidental shutoff that we were talking
about earlier
both the power switch and the backup
battery switch
are protected by this plate whether you
require
a 3 shelf or a 5 shelf configuration
unique stainless steel or aluminum racks
are available to maximize the space
energy star and app certification
attests to the cryo cube's high energy
efficiency
and low environmental impact this
freezer uses only natural
hydrocarbon refrigerant refrigerants a
plus for the environment
the cryo-cube f740hi also features a
high-efficiency
two-stage cascade cooling system and
unique
vented shelves for optimized uniformity
both of these also contribute to quick
recovery times that i mentioned earlier
as well as a quick initial pull-down
time from ambient temperature
to minus 80 degrees just over four
hours
the cryotube f740hi complements its high
quality
heavy duty components with an advanced
touch screen interface
that provides an even greater sample
protection
an integrated electronic door lock makes
protecting your samples from unwanted
visitors
easier than ever while unique user
access
allows you to limit who is allowed to
make certain changes
so for example you may wish to allow
certain people
in the lab to have access to unlock the
door
and get to their samples but you might
not want them to have the ability to
change any of the freezer settings
such as the set temperature or alarm
settings
at the same time the lab manager may
require full access to all settings and
data
so each of these users would have a
different
passcode to grant them the appropriate
level of access
all temperature and event logging is
tracked directly on board the freezer 24
7 meaning that every opening of the door
including the user who opened it and how
long it was open
is tracked along with every alarm and
event notification
security features like these really
provide an extra level of protection for
your samples
and give you the evidence to prove that
your samples have not been compromised
ensuring confidence in your research
i'll now pass it over to z
to tell us about the next product and
the sample 360 solution
see thank you kate
um hello everyone thank you so much for
joining
um i'm z i go by z and i'll be talking
about elab inventory
which is a product of elab next which is
a division of eppendorf
and on this screen here just a visual
cue here for you guys to see before i
move on to the next
slide this is a digital representation
of what your physical lab can look like
so whether you're storing your samples
in freezers in minus 80s minus 20s
maybe it is a storage room
or an acid and base cabinet whatever
your sample type is
this system allows you to customize them
uh create them
and then give them very specific
locations uh
within your actual lab and allowing you
to access it
find it and and do series of
manipulations to these samples
uh with a direct audit trail
to the things that you're doing so with
that in mind with this visual
um in mind i'll talk about some of the
the highlights of of elap inventory so
first of all uh having a digital
platform
is not enough because technically
speaking uh
google drive uh is a digital platform
as well uh user interface being very
intuitive and
allowing you to do um easy handling of
your samples is crucial especially if
we're talking about high
volumes to give you an example um i'm
currently working with a lab
that is doing uh covet 19 research
and they're managing about 10 000
samples a day
when you're speaking of such volumes
user interface is
extremely important secondly
import and export capabilities
for a software are very important for
several reasons
whether you are a an academic lab
or a health care lab that has 50 years
of research and legacy samples that
you've collected throughout the years
or a startup lab that is just starting
you might already have some excels or
other systems
that you might have used that have a lot
of crucial information
and having a system that is able to
import this information
in from other systems maybe from some
robots
um maybe creating some um automation in
the process
uh these are things that you can do in
e-lab inventory
which allows you um to um
adapt to your current environment and to
any other systems that you might be
using
um additionally um audit trail is
uh very important with these samples you
know many of you are working with high
profile samples
whether you consider them high profile
because of their cost
like some expensive antibodies or
it has it harbors a lot of intel
intellectual property within it
you'd like to know exactly what's being
done to that sample
how it's being moved around what's being
updated within it
and this is of course part of glp
compliance
which falls under the 21 cfr part 11
which allows you to um not only keep
track of your
um sample changes but also everything
else in your lab that
is uploaded in elab next elab inventory
for example uh which instruments are
being used um
who is accessing what are the
reservations that were made on a
particular freezer
all the way to the individual samples
and supplies that are being managed
and really the end result of all of this
along with all of the problems that my
colleagues have brought up
it really comes down to one common
denominator which is
you're doing less uh searching
in the lab you're doing less of these
things that used to be manual
and that opens up your time to do a lot
of more
uh actual research um that uh you've
been hired to do
um and uh we've seen labs
really scale up in their efficiency
since the implementation of elab
inventory and many of these other
eppendorf products so
i will be towards the end i'll be
available for any questions
and without further ado i'll pass it on
back to
the team with the rest thank you
thanks so much z
so inventory management of your stored
samples
is important but there is one final
component to our
sample 360 solution
visionize lab suite is a cloud-based
platform with
integrated services that provides you
the scientists
researchers and lab managers the ability
to remotely monitor your devices and
equipment
receive alarm notifications and manage
your assets
as well as simplify their device
maintenance
and as you can see with this image that
we connect to
multiple different devices so your
incubators your thermocyclers your
freezers
many different types of devices in your
lab
by connecting your devices
with visualize lab suites such as your
freezer you can remotely monitor
its activity from anywhere be notified
of alarms
and address issues quickly relevant
documents such as
sops can also be accessed using this
platform
by implementing visionize in your lab
you know your samples are safe
and you can have peace of mind
visionize labsuit can help you in
achieving your vision
by improving productivity facilitating
collaboration
and making data easily accessible
it can be customized to support you and
your lab with your ever changing needs
using a subscription-based model you can
choose which devices to connect
and add-on services you require for your
lab
such services include maintenance
management
by being able to plan for upcoming tasks
such as when devices
are due for service or pipettes for
calibration
details audit logs can also be accessed
that include device performance data
such as
parameters and user interventions such
as setpoint changes
which can be beneficial for meeting
compliance needs
and for some selected devices you can
also get
remote updates including device
improvements
and new features which makes everything
really easy and simple
so what is the outcome what do you get
by implementing a sample management
solution such as sample 360 in your lab
so first your samples are secure
they are barcoded for reliable
identification
stored in high quality organized
freezers
and can be tracked with the software
used to centralize sample data
from all storage locations and last but
not least
they're securing your freezer that is
monitored for
any alarm or issues
with secure samples your data is
reliable
and trustworthy which means you can
achieve your goals
and complete your research
your lab processes are also more
efficient the benefit
of secure samples is less time searching
for loss samples or trying to identify
them
or dealing with storage device issues
with the more streamlined process
productivity
is increased allowing you to focus on
your work
you have full peace of mind you can now
worry about
one less thing with sample 360.
so what in the end can you do you can
focus on your research
and make your next great discovery
so thank you so much for everyone for
joining us
be sure to take a survey that you would
have to just go into the
lobby and you should see it on your left
hand side
um for a chance to win an eppendorf
backpack so we will be
choosing five winners um so definitely
be sure to do that
um also explore our virtual lab to learn
more about our sample management
solution and feel free to talk to us at
the eppendorf booth as well
all right so any questions so i think we
had a few in the chat so i think
now we'll go through some of those
thank you paulina kate and z for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is
which coolant liquid could we use for
cryo cube
f740 high ult freezer
thanks jennifer um yeah i can take that
one
sure so the cryotube f740hi
uh utilizes two cooling liquids
they are r290 and r170
otherwise known as propane and ethane
these are hydrocarbon refrigerants so
they are
very friendly to the environment they're
better
much better than some of the older
hydrofluorocarbon refrigerants
that are potent greenhouse gases um
and then i think your question was just
what
what coolants do we use in this test in
the chronotube f740
um but if your question was related to
backup systems that could also be
you could use a co2 backup or a liquid
nitrogen backup
hope that answers your question
thank you and our next question here is
what should the first step for the
automation of the lab what should be the
first step excuse me for the automation
of a lab
um yeah so i can definitely take that
one so um
you know a lot of what we have talked
about today is
you know sample management which of
course is
i would say you know one of the big
important steps of automating anything
so
um you know documenting your process
understanding
what your workflow is and then
understanding you know what parts of
your workflow that you actually want to
automate
so um you know eppendorf has a lot of
different
automation solutions from you know
smaller workstations to larger
so i think you know going through your
workflow and seeing kind of
where would i need that automation help
so
you know not just for i think
automation's not just for efficiency and
productivity
but also you know to deal with difficult
liquids um
and you know for higher accuracy and
precision so i would definitely think
that it makes sense to kind of
walk through your workflow um and start
kind of
first understanding how to track your
sample
and you know how to take your sample
through the workflow
and then what makes sense to automate
all right thanks again for that amazing
answer and our next question
if i need a sample management solution
do i need to purchase
all products included in the sample 360.
yeah sure so i guess i take this one as
well so no so kind of like kate went
through um
you know this is the sample 360 solution
that you know we're definitely talking
about that we would feel is a good
end-to-end solution
but for example if you think that the
freezer and vision eyes or whatever
is would work for your lab the best and
maybe you already have other solutions
in place
then that's totally fine
all right thank you paulina and we've
got another question here
can the same principles or techniques be
used to store
sars cov2 vaccines
right uh yeah so absolutely um
the the workflow that we're presenting
here today can really be used for
absolutely any type
of sample or really anything you're
storing in your ult
freezer um z was there anything you
wanted to ask specifically about
how elab works with vaccine
yeah yeah sure um so the good thing
about
uh elf inventory is that it's highly
flexible and configurable
so whether you are working with vaccines
um with uh um i don't know cell lines
tissue or live animals
you get to create them uh within e-lab
and then define the fields that you want
to keep track of
so with that in mind
the sky is the limit um it's really
become the
the digital representation of your
physical lab becomes your playground
and uh allows you to create um
uh the the environment um
online and it actually ends up having an
effect on
your physical lab as well because now
you are thinking of standardizing
certain things
uh it affects the behavior in the lab
how you do things how often
so along with all of these other
features
that my colleagues have talked about um
with regards to automation that's
another thing that i'd mention is that
sometimes it becomes um difficult when
you think about
automation of this big thing because you
keep on adding more and more things that
you want to automate and then the
project becomes bigger and bigger
sometimes looking at the easiest things
to automate
can be that very first step for you to
build on
so there's just another note that i
wanted to add
i hope i answered your question
thank you kate and z i've got another
question and i think
z this might be more for you um what
kind of data is stored for each sample
in e-lab inventory
yeah that's uh that's a great question
um so
uh to give you an example of of covet
since
we're talking about that um let's say
you
are a company or or a
hospital that is taking samples
of from patients or people that are
giving their tests
you might want to keep track of the sex
of the patient
where they're from do they have any
pre-existing conditions
things like that but if you're working
in a cancer research lab and you are
working with
tumor tissues the the type of things
that you're keeping track of is
completely different
and the system is able to adapt to that
so
again it really does not matter what
kind of lab you are what kind of
research you're doing
everything is template driven so for
every sample type that you work with
you're able to create that sample type
from scratch
and then as you do those fields become
searchable
uh in the future so you you develop
arsenal of tools and features that serve
serve you in the future for your digital
sustainability
there's one thing that we always talk
about which is digital health
so it's it's it's not only important to
digitize
your lab for better sample management
it's important to digitize it in a way
that is healthy and and it has longevity
uh for long term and these are things
that you can do in your lab inventory
all right thank you v our next question
is
how do you purchase vision eyes to
connect all your devices
all right thank you jennifer so i can
take this one um
so with visionize you could basically
you know choose what devices you want to
connect
um and then it's basically a
subscription-based
model so you know you can
basically like you would as like netflix
or amazon or anything like that kind of
works the same way so it would just be
kind of
um like a monthly type of charge um
and yeah so you just choose what devices
and what services that you want to add
on
wow that's really cool sorry normally i
wouldn't comment but i think that's
awesome
all right so our next question is the
cryo cube energy star rated
yes it is um yeah actually
the cryo cube f740hi is energy star
rated
and it is actually also act certified
and i want to actually take this this
question as a chance to tell you a
little bit about
act in case you're not familiar with it
um
act is a label provided by my green lab
um that really looks at the
sustainability of a product
so if you're interested in environmental
concerns
it's going beyond the just the energy
efficiency part which
is also a part of the act label it takes
into account energy star data
but in addition to that it also scores
you
on a number of different things like how
recyclable is your packaging what's the
end of life for the product
all sorts of different levels
if you go to act.mygreenlab.com
you can read more about the acts label
it's it's up and coming
uh the cryo cube is actually the first
ult freezer to receive the apps label
and we're very proud of that so but yes
energy star rated absolutely
and you can certainly uh check that out
on energystar.gov
wow thank you that sounds like it's a
step above energy star even so
that's great um next question coming in
can you store the safe code cryo storage
vials in liquid nitrogen
um so yeah i'll take that one so yes you
actually can
so i know we were focusing um mainly on
you know the negative 80 ult freezers in
this webinar
but yes you can as well store them in
liquid nitrogen if you need to
all right perfect thank you and we have
time for one last question
does vision eyes only work with freezers
or other devices as well
so i could take this one as well um and
so mainly again as we were focusing on
freezers
um i did talk a little bit about that
but vision eyes
also works with other devices so
um you know other freezers you may have
in your lab as well as
you know thermocyclers and incubators
and pipettes actually as well so there's
many different devices that you can
connect vision eyes to
well thank you paulina kmz do you have
any final comments for our audience
um yeah so thank you so much want to say
kind of thank you again so much for
joining and you know taking the time to
join this webinar
and also if you're interested in more
you know the sample
360 solution or you know have questions
definitely visit our landing page which
is the eppendorf.com
sample360.
well thanks so much everyone i'm sorry
and just do you any any of
any uh you guys have any other final
comments before i wrap up
nope just thank you for joining me thank
you very much okay i didn't want to cut
anybody off
thank you again paulina kate and z for
your time today
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor eppendorf for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live
event until next time goodbye